to present the music scoring awards we
have Mary Tyler Moore and Dick Van Dyke
the most the most famous dropouts in the
history of television they're the only
two people who ever fired a sponsor hey
about every award in the business and
they win an Emmy for their appearance
here tonight I'm really gonna quit Mary
Tyler Moore I'm Dick Van Dyke
well it's a kind of exciting being again
that together again isn't it
Twiggy I really don't know what to say
me either well I guess now we know what
Carl right I lost the list that's it
it's in there
Carl's right oh the nominees are
toshiro mayuzumi for the Bible John
Barry for born free Mr Bean Bernstein
for Hawaii Jerry Goldsmith for the sand
pebbles Alex north for Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf
please give Miss Moore the Envoy
the winner is John Barry for one crew
accepting the award on behalf of John
Berry is all Rayden
the producers of Born Free join you of
the Academy in pink under the John Barry
of fine composer and he in turn has
asked them to say thank you
the nominees for the scoring of music
adaptation or treatment are Ken thorns
the funny thing happened on the way to
the forum Louise enric back alone for
the Gospel according to st. Matthew
Elmer Bernstein for return of the seven
hairy soup men for the singing nun al
ham for stop the world I want to get off
the winter please ken thorn for a funny
thing happened on the way to the forum
mr. Don black will accept the award for
Ken thorn
on behalf of Cameroon I'd like to say
thank you very much to all the members
of the Academy
the best award for the best song we have
a real triple threatening he's a singer
he's a comedian and he's an
international spy in East Berlin he's
known as Matt Helm in West Los Angeles
he goes under the name of Dean marker
well congratulations you made it how are
you oh yeah I've been waiting so long I
sobered up twice are we in East Berlin
or uh West Los Angeles we're in Santa
Monica Dean well then call me Matt are
you on duty tonight no but I got a hot
tip they're after Elizabeth Taylor no
yes yes they're gonna smuggler
measurements to Hong Kong and turn out
some cheap imitations I'll take one I'd
like it monogrammed you know Dean it's
amazing how this new careers opened up
for you everybody's saying you're the
logical successor to James Bond that
means success I'm the original oh oh
seven you are sure last time Jesus said
to me guess what I said oh seven
that's hard to believe
Dean Martin is 7up now pay attention
everybody because I'm gonna I'm gonna
read the best nominees for the I don't
know the score sorry you guys to song s
so are you indeed and that's them that
we got some surprises not on the list
but the way I read the nominees down
nominees are Burt Bacharach E or
something minor and held David for alfie
John Berry and done black 34 born free
tom springfield jim Dale for Gregory
girl Georgica
okay Elmer Bernstein that David for my
wishing doll and Johnny Oh for guys what
this last one Johnny Mandel and Paul and
friends and Webster love so you got a
letter from you something
I don't know these things to me Porter
what happened whip it out and I don't
have glasses
oh the winners are John Barry and Don
black from born free
accepting the award is mr. Don Black
on behalf of John Barry I'd just like to
thank mr. Carl Foreman and Donny
Kirchner and all the members of the
Academy thank you very much